there are new discussions about Attorney
General Jeff Sessions and people are now
talking about a possible resignation as
you might know Donald Trump's Attorney
General has already been caught lying
about his meetings and contacts with
Russian officials possibly even
perjuring himself and as a result again
as you know this is all old news
sessions has already recused himself
from anything at the Justice Department
that relates to Trump and Russia
although it's unclear whether he's
actually sticking to that as evidenced
by his name on the letter recommending
the firing of James Comey a few weeks
ago it is now getting worse for Jeff
Sessions who hinted at possible
resignation tensions continue to rise
between sessions and president Trump and
according to a number of reports that
relationship between Trump and sessions
has become so tense that at one point
Jeff Sessions actually suggested I could
resign after all now if you're wondering
why things are tense between them it's
apparently because sessions said that he
would recuse himself from russia-related
matters which the president didn't like
and only learned about minutes before
sessions publicly announced it which of
course coincides with everything we know
about how the Trump administration
handles things which is Trump's team
only finds out about things Trump is
doing minutes before or after they
happen and apparently Trump is also
finding out about things that his
administration is doing minutes before
it happens yeah and sessions also has
been blamed for the fallout over Donald
Trump's two failed Muslim majority
country travel and Refugee bans yes not
to defend Jeff Sessions here too much
but that wasn't even his fault yeah that
actually wasn't I mean I'm fine blaming
sessions for things he is actually
responsible for but that really isn't
the fault of Jeff Sessions and sources
say that sessions is just as frustrated
as Donald Trump and has offered his
resignation and asked by ABC News
if sessions threatened or offered to
resign a Justice Department spokesperson
Sarah is Gor Flores declined to comment
White House press secretary Sean Spicer
was asked if the president still has
confidence in his attorney general Sean
Spicer said I have not had that
discussion with him that is a red flag
because even when Trump says he does
have full confidence in people days
later they end up resigning
in some cases here Spicer isn't either
willing to say oh yeah
Trump has confidence in Jeff Sessions
yeah this is getting pretty crazy too
because of course first Trump fired the
acting Attorney General Sally Yates yes
any fired former FBI director James
Comey and I always you know considering
maybe a possible resonation from Jeff
Sessions it's because I think the
Justice Department is a quasi
independent organization well that's the
real angle for Trump right which is
Trump if we want to imagine why would
Trump want sessions out it would be
better for Trump to have an attorney
general who is not recused from Russia
Russian related matters and this might
seem relatively minor but it's pretty
big because if the Attorney General were
to resign not even five months into a
presidency related to conflict around
recusal 'he's made necessary by lies
related to foreign government collusion
that's major added on to the fact that
trumps national security adviser was
forced to resign in shame already and
Trump's already known for having trouble
finding people to fill roles in his
administration another high-profile
person quitting or maybe being fired is
going to make that a lot more difficult
and any replacement Attorney General
would have to go through a Senate
confirmation this is not exactly the
best time for major Senate confirmations
for Trump appointees yeah I get that but
of course any replacement over Jeff
Sessions would be a good replacement I
think I mean some cabinet choices we can
kind of tolerate like nikki Haley or
general mattis because who's the
alternative going to be sure Jeff
Sessions record on civil rights on LGBT
rights on marijuana it can't get much
worse
I want to float though another possible
situation which is would Jeff Sessions
be may be inclined to resign because his
involvement in the Russia scandal is
bigger than has already been determined
maybe there's more than just a few lies
about Russian meetings and is it
possible sessions wants to get out from
under this by resigning so that he can
turn state's witness and cut a deal or
maybe he just doesn't want to be
involved in the prosecution I think
that's why we see jason Chaffetz getting
out from Congress yes that that maybe
that maybe we're going to follow what
happens to Jeff Sessions